[Musique]
ils étaient très sur la ligne de départ
pourtant ce soir un seul candidat
remportera cette dixième édition de la
Star Academy et la team fait 4
finalistes et composé et si ce grand
retour sur TF1 laisser tout le monde
dubitatif 20 ans après l'émission Sans
bel et bien avoir retrouvé son public il
entend
que est en euphorie totale il faut dire
que le programme a tenu toutes ces
promesses une vraie école
d'apprentissage
[Applaudissements]
et quelques stars internationales
[Musique]
la recette magique de la Star Academy
c'est cette cohésion d'équipe et cette
bienveillance entre les élèves loin des
clichés habituels de téléréalité la
semaine dernière
pari réussi pour TF1 qui suite au très
bonnes audiences du programme devrait
reconduire le télé-crochet l'année
prochaine
un grand bravo alors après 6 semaines
d'aventure qui de Louis Anisha et Nola
ou Léa remportera la dixième édition de
la Star Academy ce soir on fait le bilan
[Applaudissements]
salut
je pense je trouve que tu es beau tu as
des yeux incroyables tu as du charisme
bouge bien et du sang bien c'est tout ça
et bien manager je pense que tu peux
aller très loin
on va en parler on dit non et on va pas
être tout ça en dit non j'ai des projets
pour toi je peux dire que ça va let's go
Mario je ne peux plus rien pour toi
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais bon c'est des trucs différents
[Rires]
c'est très important est-ce que tu es
célibataire absolument très bien
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai l'impression que c'est c'est le
musée Grévin vous êtes fait de cire
cette semaine non mais pardon vous avez
20 ans il ne se passe rien
tout est coupé où vous êtes juste des
asexuels
déjà donc c'est le casting c'est régalé
pour ça c'est que tout le monde avec le
cœur pris en fait c'est pas ça c'est
surtout que c'est un faux direct il y a
10 minutes de décalage
il faut couper donc c'est plus
intéressant absolument alors on va quand
même dire un petit mot sur cette finale
parce que je vous promets qu'il faut il
faut quand même la comprendre cette
finale donc ça va se passer donc ce soir
à 22h donc voilà il y aura les quatre
finalistes Anisha et Noël à Louis Léa et
donc chacun chaque élève c'est vu
composé on a vu cette semaine dans les
les quotidiennes un titre par un artiste
pour les évaluations donc on a les
quatre titres qui vont arriver alors
après il faut bien suivre les élèves je
t'ai PARLINE jusque là vous suivez ils
vont chanter ensuite en battle tous les
quatre sur le titre avant de dinde fait
somebody après vous chanter en duo avec
un artiste après bien interpréter chacun
une chanson en solo et les votes seront
clôturés et il y a donc deux élèves qui
seront éliminés qu'est-ce que tu as pas
compris qu'est-ce que ça va pas compris
parce qu'il faut suivre un petit peu
quand même à côté de précis ensuite un
solo une chanson avec le parrain de la
soirée Robbie Williams quelle chance
ensuite on va ton vote de vente il y
aura un gagnant à ton avis déjà qui sera
le gagnant franchement je te dis j'ai
vraiment pas d'avis j'en sais vraiment
rien qui soit très bonne oui
je te jure c'est vraiment tous les deux
prochaines c'est mon binôme c'est sûr
ouais on s'entraîne très bien mais ça
fait mais je peux pas faire alors
ils ont tous un truc à défendre la
quotidien
de chacun dites-moi ce que vous en
pensez donc
[Musique]
c'est moi là je vous en prie laissez-moi
moi je veux
vivre sur
[Musique]
scène
le temps j'ai appris je te pardonne je
fais comme toi ouais je sais que toi je
déconne mais dis-moi comment tu sais
c'était pas le projet quand même
pour moi Louis Louis pour moi Louis je
le vois gagner
non moi je pense que Louis a tout gagné
mais en dehors de la star
hyper commercial hyper dansant on voit
vraiment que c'est de la meilleure
j'aimerais qu'on vienne un petit peu
évidemment sur notre invité quand même
Julien parce que est-ce que je viens
nous on a une théorie au bureau ce qu'on
fait des théories au bureau et on s'est
dit qu'à chaque fois que tu avais été
nommé tu as été sauvé largement par le
public la seule fois où tu as pas été
sauvé par le public c'est juste après le
fameux talon gate où tu as refusé de
danser la fameuse tente il fallait
danser en talon et alors moi tu as tout
mon soutien là-dessus tu fais ce que tu
veux mais tu as eu cette phrase
peut-être malheureuse ou tu as dit
oui je veux garder ma dignité
et c'est vrai que c'est la seule fois
que tu n'as pas été élu par les soutenu
par des spectateurs est-ce que tu crois
que ça ça a joué un petit peu ce talon
gate
faut d'abord choisir ses mots quand on
parle aussi donc ça c'est vachement mon
problème là déjà je fais beaucoup
d'efforts ici
mais non mais c'est vrai c'est juste moi
je sais pas du tout m'exprimer donc
voilà je voulais pas dire du mal je
respecte non tout tout cet univers tout
ça vraiment je trouve ça super drôle
d'ailleurs j'étais l'assistant Yanis
pendant bien sûr le coup je trouve ça
super quoi le mec enfin j'étais son
éventail personnalisé quoi
c'est grave stylé mais voilà à partir tu
l'as dit non
j'avais un peu surtout peur de me fouler
une cheville quoi j'ai pas te mentir
aussi voilà c'est pas marchand talon sur
la phrase aurait été plus voilà mais tu
sais quoi en même temps ce que j'adore
c'est que pardon mais tous les buzz sur
les pour toi parce que il y a eu le leur
ballon game ok bah oui le ballon gate
aussi ça je sais pas si on a l'image ou
pas
bon là j'aimerais votre réaction
derrière parce que c'est quand même
assez hallucinant
et si ça te gonfle de vivre des émotions
qui sont plus profondes que toi on est
dans la merde
non mais c'est pas ça mais c'est juste
qu'en fait le truc c'est que j'ai
l'impression que vous avez vraiment du
mal à comprendre que le public met
vraiment beaucoup et on a affaire du
public oui parce que si tu respectes le
public tu le draguerais pas en caméra
juste aider à voir le sourire en fait
sur scène oui bah c'est des sourires
gratuits parce que moi quand je vois
Stan faire sa prestation il sourit je
peux dire qu'il est avec les gens et il
donne toi tu souris pour draguer non bah
non je suis désolé
je suis pas la seule
en attendant madame ballon le public
autant le talon gate bon je vous
soutiens vous faites ce que vous voulez
autant là en tant que téléspectateurs
j'ai quand même été assez choqué par le
comportement de leur ballon vous avez
quel âge
tu vas la vivre regarde let's go sans
longueur qui a beaucoup fait réagir sur
les réseaux sociaux certains même parler
de harcèlement moral vous-même vous êtes
excusé est-ce que vous êtes allé trop
loin ou est-ce que c'est l'époque qui a
changé je pense que c'est la génération
il y a beaucoup de choses qu'on ne peut
plus dire et vous savez moi je ne l'ai
pas il m'a il m'a je pense un petit peu
provoqué avec la façon dont il a dit les
choses mais je pense que ça venait d'un
endroit aussi où lui avait peur
peut-être de certaines choses moi je
suis parti avec je me suis pas excusée
mais vous savez à un moment donné quand
on veut nous on ne sait qu'on a que 6
semaines pour la Star Academy donc je
voyais que Julien n'avançait pas il
n'avançait pas donc moi j'ai voulu
essayer peut-être d'activer la machine
mais ce n'était pas maladroit et c'était
rien rien contre lui parce que
aujourd'hui on se parle Julien et moi
très bien pardon
Philippe j'adore mais il parle comme si
elle avait mis en péril la sûreté de
l'État il faut quand même arrêter et
relativiser
tu me diras ce que tu penses de la
réponse mais suite à ça et si vous avez
regardé les quotidiennes dans toutes les
quotidiens ensuite le lundi leur ballon
n'était pas seul pour le débrie qui
avait 4 Goldman qui était à côté comme
si voilà et c'est parce que vous avez
remarqué mais depuis ça tout était
génial c'était l'école des fans tu étais
génial tu étais génial mais pas génial
c'est d'être devenu ridicule le soir
comment tu l'as vécu toi bah franchement
sur le moment ça va c'était un peu
énervant je vais pas mentir sur le
moment mais après enfin voilà on s'est
expliqué elle est venue s'excuser tout
ça de ça moi aussi de parce que j'ai pu
dire aussi bah voilà on est repart sur
de bonnes bases et puis voilà c'était
fin de l'histoire
qui était étalé sur le canapé quand elle
devait faire le débrief
mais c'est pour ça que je t'adore toi tu
es un génie quoi toi tu es parti en
vacances
c'était pas du gâteau non plus et puis
je vous adore mais c'est vrai que vous
draguer la caméra
mais avec du talent pardon
vous êtes amusé mais avec du talent j'ai
raison ou pas Mario ah hahaha j'ai mangé
avec lui elle mangeait avec jean-pascan
à midi
mais il a du talent c'est pas parce
qu'il sait pas chanter sur le talent
musical c'est pas un chanteur oui c'est
pas chanteur quand même
c'est que bon pour le coup lui il y a
pas de il y a entre la télé et nous
c'est lui c'est juste lui il est
lui-même en fait on ne le transforme pas
on ne le met pas dans une cave je dis
pas tu vas faire si tu vas dire ça il
est juste lui
non mais arrêtez de là vous me faites
des gnagnagna on parle professionnel
vous connaissez tous les deux
[Rires]
ans moi les parents aujourd'hui
la famille
et autre chose et après je vous laisse
tous les chroniqueurs mais c'est vrai
que quand on dit tous les gars ils sont
arrivés par toi et ce truc incroyable ou
tu fais une évaluation je crois qu'elle
aussi tu fais l'évaluation c'est pas
beaucoup de temps c'est 7 minutes sur la
semaine tout le reste tu as rien à
[ __ ]
tu bouffes des pâtes et là tu commences
ouais je pense je sens pas du tout ça me
saoule aujourd'hui
je sais que ça va faire du buzz ou que
ça va énerver les gens moi je savais
très bien que que les gens au bout d'un
moment ils allaient se dire bon c'est
bon on a plein tu vois sortir à ce
moment-là je voulais pas sortir mais
c'est juste j'avais 42 fièvre et que
j'avais une heure pour apprendre ma
chanson et j'ai mis 2h à attendre mon
tour quoi donc au bout d'un moment la
chanson je l'avais plus dans la tête
devant
la mélodie je l'avais plus quoi
merci avec 38 ou 30 et qu'il faut monter
moi je les connais pas
stickers
bah voilà c'était moi c'était un peu
moins c'était 200 personnes c'était en
boîte de nuit au makuma Avignon mais et
que ça gueule ton nom bah là tranquille
ça fait ça un peu pour le pour le fun
quoi compositeur chanteur j'ai pas
vraiment de rêve je je pour l'instant je
teste juste ce qui me ce qui me vient à
moi en fait les opportunités je les
prends
tu prends les opportunités qui arrivent
ouais enfin voilà il est là
la personne avec lequel laquelle tu as
le prêter franchement en terme
d'artistes connus je dirais take
vraiment
je me suis éclaté mais sinon à part ça
non je dirais la performance avec mon
grand frère bien évidemment le mec il
est arrivé nulle part sur scène quoi
quoi d'accord
et ben tu sais quoi c'est la chanson en
plus parce que tu chantes tellement bien
que tu es un des seuls sur l'album de la
Star Academy la sortie à avoir qui est
sorti par avoir un solo [ __ ] c'est
vrai
c'est quand même pas rien et donc est-ce
que déjà aujourd'hui pour qu'on
comprenne bien déjà quand tu sors comme
ça d'une aventure tu as déjà la Warner
machin Sony on t'appelle pour faire un
album un truc ou tu es verrouillé
qu'est-ce qui se passe pour l'instant je
t'avoue que non enfin voilà pour
l'instant c'est un peu c'est un peu fait
ma vie un peu un peu ouais j'habite sur
Toulon
voilà et quand
la démarche dans la rue et tout ça il se
passe quoi bah franchement ça va j'ai
toujours ma vie d'avance bon de
certaines personnes me reconnaissent ils
ont pas forcément envie de venir me voir
ou me déranger ou quoi que ce soit mais
en soi non je suis pas trop je suis pas
trop sollicité quoi on voit que
l'émission a marché mais je pense que la
presse ça va être compliqué parce que il
y a pas de tournée non plus
on va parler des [ __ ] viennent
tourner ah non mais là ce soir c'est des
exclus yes on discute sur la tournée je
t'apprends ton single je vais te dire ce
qui va se passer pour toi aussi hein
quelques questions et après on reçoit la
grande mairie Paloma puis Débo moi
j'avais une question la semaine dernière
pour le prime parce que je regarde tous
les prêtres bien évidemment et la
semaine dernière tout le monde était là
s'exciter sur Twitter tout le monde est
présent sauf Julien arrête tu étais pas
là et comme je suis une fouine
j'aimerais vraiment savoir pourquoi tu
ne vais pas là pour une fois dans ma vie
les gens vont peut-être avoir du mal à
le croire mais je travaillais là je
travaille avec mon frère voilà on a
essayé de faire un petit projet et tout
une petite maquette au cas où si jamais
on m'appelle donc voilà j'étais c'était
ou pas parce que TF1 t'appelle tu
réponds dans les gars je peux pas alors
je livre des cassettes
bien sûr que je le veux mais je le veux
tellement que voilà je préfère refuser
un problème sur TF1 pour pouvoir
travailler quoi
la semaine prochaine
moi j'avoue que j'ai été assez surpris
parce que tous les sortants la première
chose que je fais c'est je les suis sur
Instagram je l'ai follow et je regarde
un peu leur parcours leur vie au
quotidien et c'est vrai que c'est plutôt
calme vous êtes tous rentrés chez vous
il se passe pas grand-chose vous faites
quelques apparitions dans des émissions
de télé mais c'est vrai que vous dites
pas oui j'ai tel projet je vais signer
pour ça je vais enregistrer ça c'est
vrai qu'on a l'impression qu'ils sont
rentrés comme ils sont ressortis pas
grand chose c'était qui moi sympathique
ah bon ah il y avait pas de moi
sympathique il y avait pas forcément
d'affinités de plus avec certaines
personnes parce que voilà mais non bah
des gens et ah non non mais il y avait
pas d'embrouille si tu veux il y avait
pas d'embrouille il y a jamais eu
d'embrouille sauf si la question mais il
y a un peu une frustration en fait moi
j'ai l'impression d'entendre mon fils à
un moment donné tu as pas envie de te
bouger un petit peu tu vois non mais
c'est pas non mais le problème de Julien
il a tellement mais c'est plus un ado tu
as quel âge déjà
des autres et c'est pour ça que tu es
pas allé aussi loin que les autres parce
que tu avais pas il y avait pas de
projet et pas d'envie on sent que tu
t'excuses d'être là ça va m'embête il
faut que je te coache je vais te coucher
tu vas venir passer une semaine
de carrière
les amis